Speaker 1: Let's. Let's go next to. Let's go
to Paul Garcia from Mexico. Paul, welcome.
Speaker 3: All right. Can you hear me?
Speaker 1: Yes, I can.
Speaker 3: Oh, okay. We've
been you've been talking about
how abortion and gang gun control can activate
Democrats vote. Do you think a Trump associate
indictment can activate Republicans to vote?
Speaker 1: You know, maybe to some degree, but not
really in the sense that when it comes to the gun
safety issue and Roe v Wade and Democrats being
activated, it's because Democrats want to change
those things by voting for different people.
Although certainly there will be Trumpists who
might hear, Oh, this Trump associate was indicted
or whatever. Who are they going to vote for?
I mean, it's like voting for your local member
of Congress isn't really going to do anything
related to that in any kind of direct way. So I
don't think it will engage and kind of involve
people and excite them in the same way. No.
Speaker 3: Do you think in like a Texas
where the the Republican governor is really
dumb and, you know, everything is going
the wrong way? Do you think we're going
to see a big change like blue wave?
Speaker 1: I think there's no evidence
right now that that's what's going to happen.
I mean, you did see you know, if you look at
Biden versus Trump in Texas in 2020, it was
the closest margin for a presidential race
in Texas for a while. I don't remember exactly
when, but but for a while. And so I do think Texas
is becoming more purple, but I don't expect
a blue any overwhelming blue wave in Texas
in the next few years. No.
Speaker 3: Okay. Thank you.
Speaker 1: All right. No problem. There's Paul
from Mexico. Good. Good question. Appreciate that.